next fall at Columbia we have a
tremendous wonderful opportunity to
celebrate romare bearden
and to celebrate Homer's Odyssey
Bearden did a series of 20 collages
based on the great Greek epic but of
course as a modern American artist he
presented a modern retelling of the tale
we're going to have programming around
this exhibition that goes all through
the year we're going to open with a
morning sidelights parade of lanterns
through the campus of images based on on
Bearden's collages and the story of the
Odyssey there will be concerts of music
directed specifically at these paintings
and it questions raised by the Odyssey
and Bearden there will be symposia
asking serious questions about
translation and improvisation and
travelling home with the idea of
addressing undergraduates as they're
studying the core but also of making our
leading scholars on campus think again
about these different questions as they
might impact their own work in lives
the exhibition contains the complete
series of collages that Bearden did in
1977 in response to his reading of
Homer's Odyssey this is a unique
opportunity to see the complete series
which has been very little exhibited it
is very exciting for us to be here in
our in our hometown in Harlem and to be
able to partner with a university that
has such a global presence and they're
so interested in Bearden and they have
so many people inside of Columbia so
many partners that are driving this and
we're just excited to be a part of
having our work done for us you know
because here we are you know always
trying to talk about Bearden and keep
him there this is going to take us a far
far way along our range every
undergraduate in Columbia College is
required to read homers on
and so there's a easy one our classes
are going to see this show there will be
class meetings in the gallery of
students consider these scenes that
they're all there we'll all be reading
about but as if that weren't enough of a
treat for our campus it's also the case
that every student at Columbia studies
Modern Art Bearden isn't required part
of that curriculum but many of the
people associated with modernism are so
that as you studied Bearden you're
studying Matisse you're studying Brock
you're studying Picasso you're studying
for that matter you're studying African
art you're studying Asian art you're
studying modernism in this context of
ancient art as well as modern the
Odyssey series is one of the most
comprehensive series of Bearden's work
and I think that it was an opportunity
for him to stretch the concepts of
collage the concepts of what the story
was about you know the universality of
the story Christi immerser and I went to
see Lee Bollinger to suggest that there
be a program or two in conjunction with
the exhibit that was coming to campus
Bollinger literally leaned forward and
said are you telling me this is Harlem
and our campus it's the core curriculum
across the disciplines it's the freshman
up through the faculty it's community
wide and New York and could involve our
global centers of course we're going to
do it this is the kind of thing we need
on the dashboard of our jetplane as we
move forward when you think about the
cross currents that this touches that
this brings together it really is quite
stunning I mean it is it is the kind of
thing that a truly great University can
both create that is the idea for
something like this comes from the
faculty
and then the institution can be brought
to bear on it and when you end up you
you have something that is no other
institution in the society can do it
we're extremely excited to have projects
presented out of the research interests
of our faculty and students as well as a
project that is of greater interest to
the broader New York arts community and
to our students specifically in terms of
its focus on Homer's Odyssey I'm hoping
on just the most elementary level that
our students will say romare bearden
that's somebody I absolutely have to
know about I'm hoping that people in the
community and I mean that and has
brought a sense as we can think of it
will think romare bearden
that's somebody I should know about he's
a Harlem I and Harlem and it's story
relates to this universal story of the
Odyssey
isn't that exciting I hope if we get
that far then I'll be the happiest man
in New York
you